ces images témoignent de la tension qui
régnait au moment de l'arrestation de
l'auteur présumé de l'attaqué
monrovia
l'intervention n'a duré qu'une trentaine
de secondes
le policier canam a brossé des seuls et
sans violence à l'arrestation du suspect
selon le chef de police de toronto
l'agent a fait un travail fantastique
sinistrés en ti au québec comme ailleurs
les policiers les experts ont salué le
travail de cet agent cep ainsi qu'à
approcher avec beaucoup de sang froid
est arrivé est allé par gradation il y a
toujours gardé le contact
je serais curieux de savoir celles
d'autres policiers dans la même
situation
combien aurait utilisé les armes à feu
pour l'ancien chef du service de police
de montréal marc parent l'intervention
était fait dans les règles de l'art je
considère qu'elle policy a fait un
excellent travail
marc parent d'ailleurs décortiquer les
gestes du policier toronto le policier
prend couverture derrière le véhicule
avec une distance sécuritaire rapidement
et le plus vraiment établir une
communication tactique verbal avec le
prévenu est aussi de tenter de le
confiner dont dans une deuxième étape
lorsqu'on le voit déployer son bâton
télescopique ce qui a évalué à ce
moment-là qu'il n'avait plus vraiment de
menace directe à son égard et ça lui
permet de lui demander justement
d'obtempérer de se coucher au sol dont
une intervention que sur une escalade
comme on voyait son arme au début mais
après ce sens qu'il reprend contrôler la
situation et roche on en sort une arme
intermédiaire la majorité des policiers
ici au canada sont formés pour
intervenir dans ce type de situation
prise mais cet ex-policier quoique
l'opération se serait terminée autrement
chez nos voisins du sud aux états unis
et ont constaté que dans plusieurs corps
similaires et rabattu le suspect aux
états unis à des cars de police comptait
pas le même niveau de formation de
compétences que l'on peut retrouver au
canada cette intervention tranche avec
celle d'un autre policier toronto james
fortios qui a été reconnu coupable de
tentative de meurtre après avoir abattu
un jeune homme de 18 ans qui brandissent
un couteau dans un tramway en 2013
le comportement de kent lahm va
contribuer sans doute à redorer l'image
de la police de toronto et 6 janvier
provient à radio canada montréal